data science with are sponsored by
simply learn sww simply learn comm get
certified get ahead my name is Richard
Kirchner and I'm with the simply learned
team what's in it for you we're gonna go
through an introduction to r yr cran
comprehensive our archive network and
cover installing our then we'll get into
simple linear regression using our line
of best fit using error summation
correlation analysis in R and then we'll
get into classification using our use
case predict the class of a flower let's
start with an introduction to our first
it's an open source R is completely free
and open source with active community
members extensible it offers various
statistical and graphical techniques
compatible R is compatible across all
platforms Linux Windows and Mac library
R has an extensive library of packages
for machine learning easy integration it
can be easily integrated with popular
software's like tableau SQL server etc
this only touches a little bit on these
different aspects of our the fact that
it's a free it's very extensive it
probably has one of the most extensive
set of data analysis package is
currently out it has a compatibility is
continually growing so it's integrated
with everything from cluster computing
to Python integration which is now
coming out and it's extension of
libraries allows you to import the
different libraries to use for whatever
your needs are makes it a very diverse
and easy to use coding source for
analyzing data R is more than just a
programming language as I just touched
upon it it has a worldwide repository
system comprehensive our archive network
and it can be accessed at HTTP colon
slash slash cran dot our project.org it
provides up-to-date versions of code and
documentation for our cran hosts around
10,000 packages of our that is a huge
repository focused on just data
analytics let's install R to get started
you can easily download the executable
file for R and install it from cran
website
if you go go under the Downloads in this
case since I'm on a Windows machine
we'll walk through it from the our 3.5
version for Windows so here we are at
HTTP colon slash slash cran our -
project.org
and you can see down here we have the
different options for the downloads if
we go under windows which is I'm on a
Windows machine if you're in a Mac
machine you do the Mac or Linux
there's install are for the first time
just click on that and open and run it
the installation is pretty simple
follow the default options to finish the
installation after the installation is
complete you'll see the our icon on your
desktop alternatively there are mirror
sites and so we can go into our studio
listed take a quick look at that if
you're on the our studio website that's
wwr studio comm you can go down under
products and our studio download you'll
see a number of options here the first
one is the our studio desktop open
source license that's the same thing you
just download it so if you download that
that's what you're getting there's also
an open source server setup which is
also free you can download from here and
then our studio offers a number of paid
packages which includes all kinds of
different supports for a company an
individual level setup whether you go
through the cran site or the our studio
site the installation is pretty simple
just a quick note if you're a Debian
distribution including a bun - you can
install are using as regular package
management tools and when you're using a
Linux system that is preferred because
it registers it properly on the setup
system let's go ahead and open up our
our studio and take a look here we are
and I've opened this up in the our
studio version which automatically opens
up some extra windows which is nice
let's go and take a look at that we have
our console on the left this is your
main workspace so if I go in here and I
do click the mouse and I do a 4+4 look
up and say the answer is 8 and you have
some environmental information and over
on the right you have plots usually when
you're working in here let's do a script
we'll go up here into the plus sign in
the upper left-hand corner and just add
some script in here in this case it
showed up on the top but you can do
these windows around unless I do y
equals 3 + 4
equals y plus two and then I'm going to
do just X and let's do a plot throw a
plot in there see sees it notation that
these are going to be Cartesian points
so we got 1 comma 2 comma 3 I'd be like
your X and then Y 3 comma 4 comma 5 for
just a standard call scatter plot you
don't have to memorize this go into some
of this later on and then I can take all
of this if I go under code since I'm
working in the code console and then go
down to run region and just run all it
takes this code and just runs it through
my console and you can see down here
it's executed y equals 3 plus 4 x equals
x plus 2 and if you add 3 plus 4 plus 2
you get 9 that's what the X does and
then I did it plot I through the plot in
there I'm plotting 1 2 3 3 4 5 if you
use just a straight plot it's a scatter
plot and you can see that this appears
on the bottom right where you have your
plots coming in so it's a very quick way
to show date and that's one of the
wonderful things about R is it's very
easy and quick to go through and do
different functions on the data and
analyze it so it's a very popular
package before you start programming in
R you should install packages and it's
dependencies packages provide
preassembled collections of functions
and objects each package is hosted on
the cran repository not all packages are
loaded by default but they can be
installed on demand remember earlier
we're talking about all the different
packages available you don't want to
install everything from R it would just
be a huge waste of space you want to
just install those packages you need so
to install packages in our studio you go
under tools and install packages when
you click on the install packages you'll
get a dialog box you'll see where as a
repository cran because there's other
repositories and you can even download
and install your own packages you can
build and then you'll pick out the
packages you want and separate multiple
with spaces or commas so you can install
numerous packages at the same time in
this case we've installing the forecast
forecast package and you can see down
here I just type in forecast all the
install all the dependencies uses other
packages to build on it has
just click on install and it's done
before we cover the basic linear
regression model let's just take a quick
look at some of the different parts of
our or parts of programming you'll need
or scripting first you know there are
various data structures in our we have
vectors we have matrixes we have arrays
data frames and lists vectors is the
most basic data structure if you
remember vectors are a location and a
direction it's how they're generally
defined although a vectors you're
talking about scripting can contain
numerous different values you can have
vectors with four or five six seven
eight different values in it for example
a picture on the computer might have the
location of the pixel and the number for
the red pew with a green hue and the
blue hue so now you have something with
five different numbers in it consisting
of that vector matrix is allow you to
move stuff around so you might have a
two by three matrix that you switch to a
three by two we looked at an XY plot
earlier it might be that you have
everything is you have ten different
numbers and each one has two values XY
and you need to switch that matrix so
then you have to raise of five numbers
arrays are just that a collection and
you can have arrays of arrays of arrays
data frames have labels on them which
makes them easier to use so usually we
use a lot of data frames when we're
working with data because they're just
easy you can have a column and you can
have a row so think of rows and columns
when you see the term data frames and
then lists are usually homogeneous
groups so an R you're looking at similar
data that's connected in the list so the
first thing we do is before we even
importing the data you should have the
data ready so we need to look at the
data and see what's going on you can
import data from various sources
including Excel Minitab CSV table text
files CSV is usually a text file comma
separated variables tab separated
variables there's all kinds of different
options here and importing the table is
very simple we have table read table
file equals data table and R equals true
and let's just take a closer look at
what we're talking about here scratch
the closer look I didn't realize it was
just for example supporting a table file
is pretty soon
you read table file equals data table so
whenever the name of the file is comma
header equals true so if there's a
header to it in this quick flash they
have name age gender will actually do
this in our with another data set in
just a minute but you can see it's very
easy to read a lot of people use are
even in other programming languages so
they can quickly look at the data before
they even start analyzing it CSV file
same thing read CSV file equals data CSV
header equals true separation equals
space so in this case even though CSV
stands for comma separated variable this
one is separated by spaces and they have
the header name age gender so it's the
same file saved as a CSV file and
there's also Excel Excel has its own
issues as far as making sure you know
what the tables are and the headers are
but you can see that each one of these
is easy to import so just like it's easy
to import the data you can also export
tables in R so you can see here right
dot table my file see my file dot txt
comma separated in the scoop T just
means this tab separated using files
example like Excel so you can write a
dot XLS to my file in this case they did
a txt separation equals scoop t so it's
a tab separated for excel file CSV same
thing very easy to write a CSV file to
your computer once you've change the
date or alternate depending on what
you're doing with it and once we have
our data imported and we can save it
afterwards and export it graphic
visualization in R is very powerful and
it's quick love doing this before even
exploring the data sometimes you just
want to graph it to see what it is there
so you have an idea of what you're
looking for so graphics in our cover a
huge amount of different things are
includes powerful package of graphics
that help in data visualization these
graphics can be viewed on screen saved
in various formats including PDF PNG
JPEG wmf and PS can be customized
according to very graphic needs you can
copy and paste in Word or PowerPoint
files are supports various types of
graphics including bar chart pie chart
histogram kernel density plots line
chart box plot heat map
cloud there's even some more obscure
ones but these are the main ones that
most people use I know I use a lot of
heat maps but word clouds are a lot of
fun if you're doing websites and did and
word analysis in histogram is very
popular all of these are very widely
used let's look at the box plots also
known as whisker diagrams box plots
display the distribution of data based
on minimum first quartile median third
quartile and maximum so right off the
bat we can use a box plot to explore our
data with very little work to create a
box plot we simply give a box plot and
the data very straightforward so we
might have passenger numbers in the
thousands I guess this is exploring data
dealing with airplanes and you can see
here they just have a simple plot if you
break it down you have your if we go
back one you'll notice we have like a
minimum a maximum our medium first
quartile and third quartile let's just
break that apart you can see the light
on the bottom is your minimum you'll end
on the top is the maximum gave your
medium and your first quartile right
there first quartile and third quartile
and the way you left as you read this is
things that are above the box are
outliers and things below the box are
outliers and what's in the middle of the
box is usually the data you're looking
at linear regression now we've have a
few tools of what R can do let's look at
the theory behind linear regression and
how that applies to what we're gonna use
an R let's understand more concepts by
solving a few algorithms
firstly linear regression which can be
applied in two ways one we can estimate
the relationship between two variables
does body weight influence the blood
cholesterol level so we just want to
know if it's even a valid connection or
not we'll size of the house affect the
house price so we can estimate the
relationship between two variables also
and then we can predict the value of one
variable dependent on the basis of other
independent variables so once we know
they're connected we want to use that to
go ahead and predict it and the cases
above maybe the body weight versus
cholesterol so the more the higher the
body weight is probably the higher
cholesterol so we first we explore is
there a connection and if there is can
we actually apply that to a linear
regression model where we can see those
how they're connected
same thing with house pricing the
simplest form of a simple linear
regression
with one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals M
times X plus C Y being the dependent
variable X being the independent
variable and being the slope of the line
which you can see over here on our graph
equals y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 and
C being the intercept or the coefficient
of the line now you don't have to
memorize all the formulas we're gonna go
in here because most of our does this
for you but you do need to know what's
going on in the backend so that you can
understand if it's working or it's not
working where the problem lies
types of linear regression there's
simple linear regression considers one
quantitative and independent variable X
to predict the other quantitative but
dependent variable Y and that's a
formula we just saw y equals M times X
plus C and then we have multiple linear
regression considers more than one
quantitative and independent variable so
instead of having just X you have X of 1
X 2 2 X 2 3 to predict the other
quantitative but dependent variable Y so
instead of looking at just body mass we
might also look at height see a body
mass and height would be two independent
variables housing prices might have to
do with the distance to a certain area
so location might be one of the
variables along with the size of the
house let's consider a sample data set
with fibrosis and find out how to draw
the regression line so in here you can
see we have independent variable and our
dependent variable we've taken some
random data in this case we have 1 2 3 4
5 4 X and we have 2 4 6 5 8 for Y and
the first thing we do is we might plot
it if you look at the plot you can see
that it has a nice line through it just
eyeballing it you can guess that there's
probably a linear regression model that
will fit this data then we go ahead and
calculate the mean we count the mean of
X and the mean of Y and you can see that
we've plotted that on there 3 comma 5
for this particular data set and so
drawing the equation of the regression
line we'll go ahead and take a summation
of X a summation of Y take a summation
of x squared and a summation of Y
squared and then x times y this is why
it's so nice for the computer
this work for you because I don't know
about you I hate sitting there with a
calculator and if you have just five
variables that would be very long not a
big deal but if you're doing hundreds of
variables definitely much easier to let
the computer do it all so the intuition
behind the regression line breaks down
to the linear equation which is
represented as y equals M times X plus C
in this case M equals this very lengthy
formula we have your some nation's so
all the values that we've already
computed fit right into this equation
and so you have n being the number of
variables that's what the N stands for
your x times y we computed the sum of X
sum of Y over the number of variables
times the sum of x squared minus the sum
of x squared and then of course we have
put the numbers in and you get a value
of 1.3 and you find out that your C is
equal to one point one once we have this
formula we can easily compute the Y
values y equals M times X plus C equals
one point three times three plus one
point one equals five and this would be
the example of x equals three you could
also put in x equals 6 and then know one
value let's find out the predicted
values of y for corresponding values of
x using the linear equation where M
equals one point three and C equals one
point one so here's our regression line
and then you can see if we put in all
the numbers one two three four five we
don't get the exact prediction because
it's a line through the data you'll see
that it ever so slightly off two point
four three point seven five six point
three seven point six but it is a good
estimate of what the data is going to
generate let's find out the predicted
values of Y for corresponding values of
x using the linear equation where M
equals one point three and C equals one
point one the best fit line should have
the least sum of squares of these errors
also known as a square the predicted Y
value residuals of errors the actual Y
values so one of the things we're
looking at when we put this information
together as we want these distances to
mid be minimized so as the smallest
amount of error possible let's find out
the predicted values of y for
corresponding values of X using the
linear equation where M equals one point
three and C equals one point one and
here you can see we've done the same
kind of chart we have our Y predicted
and then we have the actual Y minus the
Y
predicted because we are looking for the
error squared or the e squared values
the sum of the squared errors for this
regression line is three point nine we
checked this error for each line and
conclude the best fit line having the
least square values minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error is set no matter how you
compute the errors you can see here this
is what it's basically going through
taking the line it's Lily adjust it
until it has the minimal error available
the minimal distance between the line
and the different data points use case
we'll start with linear regression and
then we'll jump in and also do a
decision tree so you can see how they
are same and how they differ and the way
they function and what they're used for
and while we're going through the use
case you can start linking the theory
behind it connected to the actual use
and as you connect those dots you can
see that by making changes in the model
based on the theory you can also fine
tune it we'll talk about that briefly as
we go through this for this analysis
will use the default cars data set to
find the correlation between variables
cars is a standard built in data set
that makes it convenient to show linear
regression in a simple and easy to
understand fashion and we'll start with
head cars and string cars now I've gone
ahead and removed the script on here to
make this easier to see and we don't
have to do any kind of importing of data
because it's already in there I'm just
gonna type in head and cars and hit
enter and what you're gonna notice is
it's going to display the first six rows
one two three four five six and you'll
see speed and distance now this is a
little bit like a spreadsheet so if
using an Excel spreadsheet it should
look the same this is a standard data
frame kind of setup in this case when
you rece a head usually lists the first
number of rows depending on your package
in R it starts with 1 and then it does
the first six rows string and we do a
string of cars it's gonna break it down
and show us it as a data frame it has 50
objects that's with the 50 obs of two
variables and then we have speed the
first variable is going to be a numbers
um stands for four four seven seventy
two starts listing the date of their and
distance now I'm assuming the speed is
the speed of the engine otherwise if
it's the speed of the car then the
distance should always be the same and
that would be kind of silly but this is
the speed of the engine and based on the
speed of the engine can we correlate
that to the distance let us visualize
the data using scatterplot to understand
the relationship between predictor and
response and I want you to notice that
in this slide a line has been drawn
through the data now when we first start
with data you don't have that line so as
we plot it I want you to kind of
visualize that line there and just kind
of say hey does this stuff kind of
scatter around a line or not before we
actually create the model and we simply
do plot and I'm gonna do a shorthand
here cars and a hit enter and it comes
over here to the right and plots our
data for us now because there's only two
variables I don't have to do anything
special I'm gonna expand this over
environment so we can see it and you can
see you can just visualize a line right
through the data and it's all clumped
along that line which makes it really
nice for doing a linear regression model
now I did something a little tricky here
because I'm very lazy I typed in plot
cars a lot of times you don't want to do
that because you don't want to plot all
the data we could do plot in this case
cars dollar sign speed the first
variable cars dollar sign distance when
I do that I get the same plot all I'm
doing is telling you to use just these
two columns of data and although the
first one is quick and easy if you only
have two columns of data the second one
is what you really want to do when
you're plotting data like this you want
to control which columns you're using
and then we want to do a correlation
correlation analysis studies the
strength of relationship between two
continuous variables it involves
computing the correlation coefficient
between the two variables if one
variable consistently increases with
increasing value of the other then they
have a strong positive correlation of
value close to one and again I can just
type in correlation car's the short form
and we can see we have a nice
correlation going on there between the
two but we really want to do those we
want to do we want to correlate cars and
then we're gonna do the speed comma cars
and the distance and so when you look at
this actually hit the enter key in the
middle of that which is fine you can
in our do it line by line so if you're
trying to do a bunch of different
columns you might want to do that to
make it easier to read and you can see
here I get the point eight zero six
eight nine four so this has two one the
more these correlates was saying there's
a pretty good correlation positive
correlation between the two variables
and if you look at it what I did just
cars which did the correlation over all
the variables you'll see that speed
correlates with speed one hundred
percent because they're the same that's
just the nature of that but when you
look at speed versus distance we get the
point eight zero six eight four nine and
if you do distance to distance you get
also one since they're identical
variables so now it's time to build our
linear regression model on the entire
data set to build the coefficients let's
just take a look and see what that looks
like back in our console and then type
in linear mod and in our we want to do
the arrow cut like an arrow in a line or
in this case the less than minus sign
that's the same as assigning whatever
we're going to put after it to this
variable so we're creating the linear
variable L M stands for linear module
and we're gonna look at speed and
distance so we put the little squiggly
bracket between them this lists are no
we're gonna deal with these two columns
comma data equals cars and when I hit
enter on here we've generated our linear
mod now we want to go ahead and
summarize it and we simply do a summary
and then brackets linear mod and it
generates all kinds of information on
our model so we can explore just how
well this model is fitting the data we
have right now now if you did linear
regression and other packages and
scripts you're gonna see that this is so
easy to explore data in R so even
somebody who's working in say Python or
SPARC Hadoop coming back to the our
console to do some basic exploration of
the data is very beneficial and if you
use just our R goes into all kinds of
different packages and you can even do
cluster computations through h2o are
there's a lot of cool things this is
what makes our so wonderful is how
easily we can summarize something like a
linear model and to explore this data
let's go back to the slide and we'll see
here where it says the residuals the
first one Q stands for first quadrant
median third quadrant max coefficients
we
first what to do is look at the estimate
standard deviation on here and you'll
see the intercept is at minus seventeen
point five seven nine one and speed
three point nine three to four so we can
compute the distance equals to the
intercept plus the beta times the speed
which just means that we can assign a
distance equal to minus seventeen point
five seven nine plus the three point
nine three two times the speed the value
of P should be less than 0.05 for the
model to be statistically significant
and this is one of the things I love
about are you can see right down here
and we punched in the numbers and even
tells you the significant coats so if
you're trying to guess or remember it
tells you right away hey this one point
four nine to the minus twelfth is way
below 0.001 on there and even puts three
stars next to it so you can see that
that is a very high correlation and you
can see the 0.01 to three gets one star
because it is greater than the point oh
five or it's less than the 0.05 so this
shows that there's a very high
correlation statistically is very
significant so now we're gonna go ahead
and create a training and a test data
set and the first thing we want to do is
we want to set the seed so the sample
can be recreated for future use remember
at all these different regression models
they usually have some randomization
going on in the back to kind of fit it
and guess where it's gonna go and if you
want everything to match you want to
start with the same seed in that
randomizer that way recreates it
identical every time you run it on a
different computer and just like working
with data in any package we're gonna
create indices for the training data and
we're gonna model the training data and
then we're also gonna do the test data
and build our model on the training data
let's walk through that and see what
that looks like an R and actually
mistyped that one let's type in set dot
seed to set our seat for the 100 let's
go
training row index and that's our name
we're making up for our variable and
we're going to set that to sample now
sample is a command in R so we're going
to take a random sample of some of the
data and then we're going to do one
colon
in rows cars so this is the number of
rows and cars and we're gonna start with
one and sample them so Row one of the
data we're skipping any of the titles on
the top and then in the sample there's
two variables ago and the first one is
the in rows of cars and then we want to
do 0.8 times in rows of cars this
basically says we're gonna take 80% of
all the rows in the car sample we'll hit
enter to go ahead and run that we see
here that I had an error and that is
because it's in row actually putting s
on there that's something I do a lot on
will just fix that real quick brings up
a point that if you use your up down
arrow you can quickly paste through the
last things you typed in and then you
can reuse them so there we go now I have
my training row index which is basically
a list of all the rows we're going to
use right now that we have a training
row index we'll go ahead and create our
training data variable and we'll assign
that cars and I'll put that as a
training row index and this is supposed
to be brackets because we're dealing
with a raid type format we want to do
the training row index comma so we just
need the index of the row and as far as
the columns we want all the columns so
here we have our training data and now
we set up a training data we also need
our test data and with our test data
we'll assign that also to cars and
because we use the training row index
and we use the sample to create it we
can simply do a minus sign training
index comma so it's identical to the
training data but the test data is going
to be the ones the rows or we're not
included in the random sample of any
percent so it's gonna be 20% of the data
of course it's very easy to do mistakes
on here so we'll come back into this
bring back up the error and then we have
training and a training index training
row index there we go very easy correct
errors and our so now we have our
training data and our test data so we
have 80% in training data and 20% in
test data and let's go ahead and create
our model we'll call it
LM mod and this is identical to what we
did earlier here's our linear model
we're going to have
are two different columns if you
remember above we had to tell it which
columns we wanted I'm gonna do distance
and speed and then the data we're gonna
set equal to training data so as opposed
to doing all of cars we want to use just
the training data on here and now that
we've created a model off of the
training data we need to go ahead and
run our prediction off of our test data
we want to see how the test data which
has nothing to do with the model so far
how well it fits and we call a distance
predict there's our assignment so we're
going to assign the value to it and with
our we type in predict and then we call
their model we go ahead and pull up our
model LM mod and so we're gonna use that
model and then we want to put in the
test data here's our test data and so
now we're creating the distance predict
variable and we're going to put all the
information as far as predicting on our
tested data and we'll run that just hit
the enter key and then if you remember
from before we want to review the model
diagnostic measures and so we're gonna
go in here and do a summary and you'll
see in here we have a couple different
things going on but let's go ahead and
take a summary of this and just walk
through what this means so summary and
then we call that LM mod and we hit
enter and it pulls it up and we have a
nice summary of our LM mod and the first
thing we're gonna note is that the data
is right now in our LM mod that we're
summarizing is our training data and
let's go back to the slide and highlight
this so the data equals the training
data that's where the LM mod comes in
residuals we have our minimum our first
quarter medium third quarter in the max
or quadrant not quarter you think I was
doing business analysis as opposed into
the year taxes in first quarter versus
quadrant we look at our coefficient we
can see where our intercept is and our
speed is and we know it over here or
significance codes so they all match up
so a simple correlation between the
actuals and the predicted values can be
used as a form of accuracy measurement
so we took a look at the model we
created and now we need to take our
predictions and just see how accurate it
is on the data that we didn't use to
program the linear model so let's create
a variable called actuals and
score predicts and assign it data frame
this is how we create a data frame as we
just assigned data frame yeah we'll do a
see bind and in our c bind we're gonna
take our date and we're gonna create a
column called actuals so this is our
choice to name actuals this is going to
equal test data and we're gonna use a
dollar sign and distance and we've
already got a little room there so let
me pull this over so we can see it
better
there we go distance and then we also
want to take and compare that to what we
predicted for the other data and we'll
call this column predicted and that's
going to equal our distance predict
remember distance predict is set to the
predicted values of our test data so
what this is is we're saying hey here's
our test data the actual data and the
distance and then we have what we
predicted that distance to be and we'll
go ahead and assign that we can do a
quick head actuals predicts there we go
remember head shows us it's a data frame
so it's going to show us the labels in
the first set of data in this case
you'll notice that the rows have a
different count they're not one two
three four five six
well we randomly picked twenty percent
of the data so this is the first six
rows of that random selection which
comes out as one four eight twenty 26 31
and we have the actuals so the actual
value is two and the predicted value in
this first one is minus five so they're
way off 22 seven twenty six twenty
twenty six thirty seven fifty four to
forty to fifty to fifty so one of these
is pretty right on where a lot of them
are really off at the beginning let's
just see what that looks like though
because just eyeball on the first six
rows does not tell us what's really
going on so let's create another
variable correlation accuracy and we're
going to assign this correlation cor
member we do a cor and we have our
actual predictions so let's just see how
our actual values versus the prediction
correlate with each other and we sign
that one actuals underscore predicts
there we go let it auto finish for me
and we can just go ahead and type in
correlation accuracy and see what that
looks like
so we have an actual Swan a predicts
point eight and you can see how they
kind of correlate we have the
8:2 and if you remember from before
we're looking for either 0.001 0.01 0.05
0.1 that is a p-value which we're not
looking at here this is not based on the
p-value this is based on we looked at
earlier with correlation that the closer
to 1
the closer the values are and so 0.82
gets upwards of 1 so you see that
there's a normal pretty much a
correlation in here but we want to dig a
little deeper this doesn't really tell
us how accurate it is for that we're
gonna use another tool for that we're
gonna calculate the min max accuracy and
MAPE and the min max accuracy equals the
mean value of the minimal actuals and
predicts over the max value of the
actuals and predicts and then the mean
absolute percentage error or may pass
it's called equals the mean of the
absolutes predicted minus actuals over
the actuals that's a lot to follow as
far as remembering all these different
math and theory behind it cool thing
though is it's all done pretty much for
you so you can compute all the error
matrixes in one go using the regress
eval function in d MWR package since
this is the first time I've used this
install I'm gonna have to install the DM
WR package so we can actually install up
to different ways if you remember we
talked about installing packager Li er
we can go under tools and install
packages and I certainly could type in
DM WR even comes up and lets me know
that's one of the main packages up there
well that's a tool of the our Studio
setup you can also install this using
the console we simply type in install
dot you can even see here it comes up
install packages and then DM WR when I
hit enter I should do the same thing as
the other one does it goes through and
installs a DM WR package it takes just a
moment to zip through all the different
package setup and then the format for DM
WR is DM WR we're gonna go : : you're
specifically looking at the regression
dot eval and then we're gonna do actuals
underscore predicts and we'll go ahead
and put in the individual columns on
this one so we
actuals love the Auto Thai typing and
then again actuals predicts and this
time you want to do it against the
predicted go ahead hit enter on here and
you'll see in here it comes up with our
ma e MSE our MSE and the MAPE values so
we looked at the linear regression model
let's go ahead and take a look at the
decision trees so let's go ahead and
talk about another algorithm decision
tree decision tree is a tree shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents the possible decision
occurrence or reaction there's a tree
which helps us by assisting us in
decision making let's look at the basic
terminologies to understand decision
trees we have our root node we have a
splitting we have decision node decision
node and then those split into terminal
node decision node terminal node
terminal node and each decision node
continues to split until it ends in a
terminal node note a is the parent node
of B and C also no we call the terminal
nodes leaf nodes you can also see that
we have a branch or a sub tree so when
you have a split everything under that
split under one side is called a sub
tree you cannot build your decision tree
without knowing entropy and information
gate entropy entropy is the measure of
randomness of impurity in the data set
so we have here a bunch of fruit and you
can see we have looks like apples
oranges and bananas it's very chaotic so
it's a very random data set as a very
high entropy and if we take out one
group let's say we take out the apples
it's a little less random now we only
have bananas and oranges so it's a less
random data set and we have lower amount
of entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or impurity in the data set
so when you have a homogeneous data set
we will have entropy equals zero and
here you can see it's all oranges an
equal divided data set will have an
entropy equal to one so here we have
half or what is it looks like a couple
bananas a couple oranges and a couple
apples so everything is equal so we have
an entropy of one on there since there's
two of everything
information gate it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
so we look over here we have an entropy
equals e one and the information gained
as we split the bananas out the size
becomes smaller and you'll see that he
one is going to be greater than e2 or
remeasure e two of the apples and
oranges in this case if you love your
fruit it's probably getting you hungry
right about now and then the information
gained from our level two equals e2
minus e1 where e 2 is greater than e 3
as we come down here we'll see that the
e 3 is now the third level we split the
oranges and apples out and each time
that entropy becomes less and less and
less until in this case we have an
entropy of zero since they're all
homogeneous in their order all oranges
all apples all bananas so let's take a
look at the use case decision tree and
actually put this into code and see what
that looks like as we go from theory to
script and to predict the class of
flower based on the petal length and
width using R and you'll see here we
have these beautiful irises probably the
most popular data set for beginning data
analysis and statistics we have thus
Atossa the virginica and the versicolor
let's install the packages that will
help us in the use case so because we're
doing decision tree we have our part our
part not plot and then we have the
library our part and the library our
heart plot let's go ahead and take a
look at that if you remember we have two
ways of installing it we can do the
install packages we did that earlier
here we go install packages using my up
arrow to get to it or we can go up to
tools install packages and I can do our
part and our part dot plot and then go
ahead and hit the install measures that
will be updated currently loaded looks
like some of them already loaded that's
fine we'll just go ahead and update
those and once we have those updated
let's take a look and see what we have
going on here
I'm still loading yeah let's go ahead
and type in library our part and library
are part plot so we want to bring it
into our console with we're working in
so what but now we just download the
packages and now we want those libraries
available to what we're doing
so the iris although it's built into the
r package download on the basic download
we actually have to install the data or
bring the data in so we're gonna do the
data iris and then we're gonna do the
string iris
let's just flip back on over to our our
studio and set up our data iris and then
we're gonna do the string before we do
that let's do head head iris there we go
and you can see the head has sepal
length sepal widths petal width length
petal width species in this case the top
part salsa Tosa and each row gets a
number and then we did the string iris
and that comes up with information and
if we flip back to our slide you can see
here the structure of the database under
string is it's a data frame as a hundred
and fifty objects five variables each so
each one has five variables all features
are numerical except species which is
categorical as it is our target variable
which we want to predict so we want to
predict whether there's going to be a
varicose ax versicolor so Tosa so you
can see here we want to predict all the
features are numerical except species
which is categorical it is our target
variable which we want to predict
remember that's asset OSA the versicolor
the virginica
the three different categories we saw
earlier in the beautiful pictures of the
flower so we're going to go ahead and
use the set seed to decide the starting
point used in the generation of sequence
of random numbers remember we set the
seed so that if we ever want to
reproduce what we're doing it will
reproduce the same thing each time
because using the same randomizer seed
bring slightly different results but
depending on what you need it for and
then we're gonna generate random numbers
using run if and the question is why do
we want to create random numbers on here
it's kind of an unusual thing to do for
in rows iris let's go back and just take
a quick look here actually want to go
back to our our studio and you're gonna
notice when I did the head of iris what
do they have I had sat OSIS a ptosis at
so ptosis a ptosis atossa so the data is
organized by species and it's already
grouped them together in the data set
well we want to randomize that so that
doesn't affect our output and then we'll
go ahead and take and create our iris
ran well we recreate the data frame
based on a random order instead of Satou
so all being grouped together let's go
ahead and put that into our our studio
and set seed and will match their number
98
this way we'll have identical results to
what they're doing on the slides we're
gonna set the variable J G equal to run
if and face this on in row of iris and
finally we're gonna create iris
underscore ran and we're gonna assign
our variable we're creating iris
underscore ran and we'll set that equal
to I'm gonna do that the original
database where I set that equal to Iris
and we need brackets because we're
signing the valuables and we want to
change the order so there's an actual
command order we can do it's going to be
order G so this means all the rows in
the order that G is so we just
randomized all those rows and then we
want to keep all the columns so we'll
just put a comma and leave a blank for
the columns so now iris ran will have
some randomized rows coming in and if we
do let's just do this real quick
iris ran we can see there's no longer so
ptosis Atossa we now have virginica so
Tosa versicolor setosa and you can see
the road numbers at the beginning we
have 103 2060 317 so they're randomized
on there pretty well now that we've done
a little data manipulation we can go
ahead and build our model using our part
as follows the things I want you to
notice here is we're gonna build our
model for our our part on the first 100
because our data equals Iris ran one to
a hundred
there's a hundred fifty objects so we're
keeping a third of them off to the side
that way we have our training set and
our tests had already pre-built because
we randomized the rows going in from the
beginning and then once we've done that
we want to go ahead and print our model
out and take a look at it let's go ahead
and put this into our our studio and
take a look and so we have our model
we're going to call it model that's our
variable name that we're giving it we're
gonna sign that our part and in brackets
we'll start with species and we want to
correlate species to all the other
columns so how do we do that
and the shorthand is just to put a
period there and then we're going to put
a comma and we want to set our data
equal to Iris ran that's Adina we put in
there and remember I say we're gonna do
just the first hundred rows so we can
save the last 50 for testing so we can
do
simply by doing row 1 to 100 so an or
you start with one for your rows and
because we want all the columns we just
put a comma and that did note so we're
gonna use all the columns in here and in
the art part there's different
methodologies we're using the method
equals class you realize that we're
doing a classification between the three
different types of flowers since this is
what we want to go ahead and set up our
model with and when we run that we've
now created a nice model for us we can
go and just type in model hit enter and
you'll see I'll print out a bunch of
information about our model so let us
know what's going on in there and let's
just break that down and see what that
looks like so we have our target our
predictors
that's species and it's gonna relate to
we used a period to denote all the
columns we're gonna take the first 100
rows to train the data and we have the
defining method to be used as
classification that's what the method
equals classes and we want to do next is
we're gonna do a plot take a look and
see what this actually looks like a
little visual here which is nice and we
can simply do that with our plot for the
model and let's break this down a little
bit to see what that looks like in the
our set up when we do this our part dot
plot a little bit of a mouthful there
sometimes that's part of the art part
package or module so when you imported
this in it also included its own
plotting format we're gonna send it our
variable model there are actually a
number of types of plots listed for our
part but we're just going to type equals
for fallen leaves'
equals T and extra equals 104 that's
going to hit enter on there and you'll
see right over here on the right hand
side it goes into our plots we just
enlarge that large that we have our
Mercer color or so Tosa versicolor
virginica let's go ahead and break that
down because he down here it represents
the tree is it splits it looks at it and
says hey if the petal dot length is less
than 2.6 it's gonna be asset Ossa so
thirty-four percent of them fall into
that category and if the petal length is
greater than 2.6 it looks at that and
says okay now I have three different
variables we're gonna split it again
petal width is lesson 1.7 is going to be
a
the color and if it's greater than 1.7
it's a virginica and so you can see here
we it's very simple tree of forms it's
only got a couple levels you can see a
branch off to the right very nice
depiction of what's going on as far as
the model now that's created but once we
create the model we need to figure out
is this model any good so let me go back
over here and let's go back to our
slides and the first thing we're gonna
do is we're gonna take our test data
remember we saved 50 rows for the end to
go ahead and run a predict on there so
let's go ahead and run that prediction
so we'll call it model underscore
predict and we're gonna get a run button
there to predict what are we gonna
predict we're going to predict our
initial model and we need to send the
data so data equals and we don't
actually have to put the data part and
we'll just put an iris underscore ran
and then we want to do just the last 50
rows and we denote that by 101 colon 150
and then comma and we'll leave that part
blank since we want all the columns to
show up and then finally this is a
classification so we need to let it know
that type equals glass there we go
let's just see what that looks like
model predict and so this is what the
data is put out as it says whatever this
is 131 is a virginica number 10 is asset
OSA line number 95 is a versicolor and
so on all the way through but we really
want to know is how good our model is so
we're gonna go ahead and install a
couple more packages we're gonna install
the packages required to use the
confusion matrix and to do that we're
gonna install carrot and 107 one and
then of course we want to set them to
our project by using the library command
and so we can simply install packages
and we want carrot and just do that
right there there's carrot installed I
went ahead did the install for packages
II 107 1c it goes through there it's
really quick install compared to the
carrot and then once we've installed the
packages we need to load it into our
workspace so there's our library carrot
there it goes
when SAS loaded we'll go ahead and also
load the or set the library to the e10
71 so that we have both those libraries
available to us now these two libraries
are fully available to us and then we're
gonna use these tools to create the
confusion matrix matrix this is the iris
ran and then go ahead and put the
brackets here we're only gonna do 101 to
150 and then we only want the first five
columns at the last I call them the
first five columns so five in there
we'll set that to our model predict and
then we hit enter it's gonna head and
just print out all this information so
right here we're looking at our
confusion matrix to see how everything
kind of balances out let's go over that
and see a little closer what that
actually means so the first part we see
is a reference and in here we have our
prediction because that's what we call
the column if you remember correctly and
we have it for sat OSA versicolor
virginica and then we have Satou
subversive color virginica going down
each side and the way you read this is
if you look at this we predicted 16 out
of 16 so Tosa and then versicolor we
predicted 13 of the versicolor
and then two of those we predicted as
virginica so we were wrong on two of
those and with the virginica we
predicted 17 correct and we had two
wrong they were versicolor so we look at
the overall statistics on here and we
have an accuracy 0.92 and a 95% CI
that's pretty good as we're going
through here those are good deals on
that there's a lot more information as
you go down this one thing I want to
remind you on this as we're looking at
these predictions and this is also true
for the linear regression model we
looked at earlier when we talked about
the accuracy that is the accuracy on
this data and we say that as a
programmer to make that a very clear
distinction because if you're in data
analysis you should cringe if I say oh
this is a 95% accurate model without
that put in there because bad data in
bad data out we won't go into detail
right now on that but that is a very
important to note that whenever
quote any of the accuracies on here or
you discuss any of these values that
come up so quick summary introduction to
our we went over the fact that you can
import data very easily from a table an
Excel spreadsheet a CSV file you can
also export it we went over the
regression line of best fit and how that
is those formulas work to slowly adjust
that line until it fits with the least
amount of error we discuss correlation
analysis in R where we're correlating
data between two objects and then we
talked about the decision tree algorithm
and model building and validation thank
you for joining us for more information
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor